Welcome to "English in a Minute," where we teach you about idioms in American English.
If you have heard American English, you have probably heard this:...
..."It's a dime a dozen."
What does this phrase mean?
Let's find out.
There's no need for you to pay 20 dollars for that hairbrush, it's too expensive.
Why not?
I really need it.
The store down the street has them at a dime a dozen.
Come on, I'll show you.
When you say something is "a dime a dozen,"...
...it means that there's a lot of it, it doesn't cost much or that it isn't special.
"It's a dime a dozen."
This is a common way of saying that something is so easy to get that it doesn't have much value.
And that's "English in a Minute."